-Our first guest tonight is a
very talented actress, comedian,
and singer who you know from her
work on "Saturday Night Live,"
"Wine Country,"
and "A Clusterfunke Christmas."
She stars in "American Auto,"
which returns with new episodes
Tuesday nights at 8:30
here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-I tell you
it's going to be okay
so that you all don't panic,
okay?
I mean, outside I'm like,
"Hey, guys, everything's
going to be just fine.
Brighter days tomorrow.
Cheer up, okay?"
Do you want to know
what I'm thinking inside?
Would you like to know
what I am thinking inside?
-Yeah, yeah.
-[Bleep]
[Bleep]
[ Shouts ] [Bleep]
-Please welcome to the show
our good friend Ana Gasteyer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello.
-Hi.
-How are you?
-Isn't this fun?
-It is so fun to have you back.
It is so fun
to have the show back.
This is a very classic sitcom,
and I'm very pleased by the fact
that a few of them
are coming back right now.
We have a show like this.
We, of course,
have "Abbott Elementary"
with the great Quinta Brunson.
And you had a moment
at the Golden Globes
where you and Quinta
ran into each other,
and this happened on-camera,
and people were very excited.
-She went viral.
-Yeah.
That's exciting.
-Not Quinta, but the clip.
-Yes, this moment.
And going viral
has always been your goal.
-Well, I'm a --
I'm very into the Internet.
-Yeah.
-I have always been.
-Always,
from the very beginning,
you said,
"There's something here."
-I said -- when I clicked on
to my old-timey IBM portable,
it was 740 pounds, and I said,
"This is going to be big."
-Yeah.
You had it on wheels.
I remember you would push it
around the office.
You said
it's a portable computer,
and you really had to
put your back into it.
-I really did.
I said, "Don't call him HAL
'cause he'll try to kill ya."
That's a deep cut.
-Oh, that's a deep cut
for our Kubrick-heads
in the audience.
Do we have our Kubrick-heads?
Some people are leaving,
I notice.
Okay, so...
-Okay.
-Now, real quick.
This went viral.
-Okay, so I was at
the Golden Globes,
and so was Quinta.
And when we got
to the Golden Globes --
'cause you're super dressed up
and there's that red carpet.
And my publicist leaned over
and very sternly said,
"You are on-camera constantly
on this carpet.
So be aware," okay?
So I immediately forgot
that there were cameras going,
so you can imagine.
And I walked along,
and then I saw Quinta.
And she has been so supportive
of "American Auto"
and we of "Abbott Elementary."
It's been kind of fun
'cause it's like
this network renaissance
of the half-hour comedy.
-Yes, and these just wonderful
big-cast shows.
-Yeah, like old-timey, you know,
just good network comedies.
None of these dumb streamers.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, boy.
It's so funny
'cause you love the Internet
and you hate the streamers.
-I hate the streamers.
I like to -- I like
to buy things on the Internet
while I'm watching network.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway...
[ Laughs ]
Yeah, so Quinta and I,
we embraced
because she's been very sweet
about "American Auto,"
and we had a big embrace.
But we were both
in these kind of --
almost like French
courtesan dresses
with our ta-tas really jacked.
-Yeah.
-And we had a --
It was one of those weird things
where you embrace,
and we had so much --
We had a breast mash
is what happened.
-Yeah. Gotcha.
-We had so much flesh contact
just in the bust area
that it had to be acknowledged.
-Right, yeah.
-Do you know what I mean?
It's like when you have a thing
where you, like --
when you French-kiss sometimes,
and then it's clear that
you're going for the fourth --
Not French-kiss.
What's that called?
-Um, yeah.
Sort of the European,
like, mwah, mwah.
-Yes, not a deep tongue.
That's different.
But you should acknowledge that.
-Yes.
If you ever French-kiss someone,
certainly in this age
of consent,
you should definitely
acknowledge that it happened.
-Okay, so anyway,
we just started laughing
'cause we had the breast mash,
and our breasts met
so much further in advance
of our conversation.
-Gotcha.
-So we just started laughing.
And then, I don't know,
of course it was on-camera,
as predicted by my publicist,
and it went completely viral.
Somebody from Poland
sent it to me, literally.
It was like [Polish accent]
"Ha-ha, you are so funny
with your breasts"
[Normal voice]
or something like that.
-That's an excellent --
No, don't sell that short.
That's an excellent
Polish accent.
-Northwestern trained.
You go deep.
You would never do an accent
without doing a year
of research.
-Absolutely right.
That's absolutely right.
-You take it very seriously.
-I don't learn the language.
I just learn the International
Phonetic Alphabet pronunciation.
-You mentioned -- So we both
went to Northwestern University.
And now you've got a daughter
at Northwestern University.
-I do.
-What a trip.
Frances is there.
-Frances is there.
She's a junior.
She's a theater major.
-So she's really following
in her mother's footsteps.
-She's not doing improv.
-Okay.
-Like, she drew the line.
-Okay, so that's interesting.
What turned her off of improv?
-Me.
-Okay.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I get it.
-Yeah, it was simple.
Shame. Yeah.
-Shame.
She just didn't want to follow
that closely.
-No.
She's a really good writer.
I mean, I think
she would do improv,
but I think she was like, "It's
bad enough that you went here.
I'm not going to --"
-Gotcha.
-Understandable.
-No, exactly.
You got to at some point just --
-Got to find your way.
-Yeah, find your own way.
But is she thriving there?
-She is. She loves it.
She's directing things.
She directed her first musical.
-Amazing.
-Yeah, it's pretty exciting.
-And then your son, Ulysses,
he's 14.
What about him
in your footsteps?
-He definitely loves comedy.
-That's good.
-We're working on his education.
-His comedy education?
-Yes.
Well, because, again, I like
the old-school Internet,
but the TikTok comedy
needs development.
-Okay, gotcha.
-Okay?
-You feel like it's
a little undercooked?
-Yeah, it's undercooked, 'cause
you know what's not a sketch?
A guy in a hat that turns around
and says one thing.
-Okay.
-That's not a sketch.
-Yeah.
-That's a funny guy in a hat.
-But what if you saw him
a second before without the hat?
What if he didn't have the hat
and then he turns around
and now it's still him
but he's got a hat?
-Or if there's that
international lady that goes,
"Me when my mother comes home
from dinner,"
you know, whatever.
-Yeah.
-That's not a sketch.
It's not a sketch.
-I will say,
you do it very well,
and I think you would thrive
if you had an account.
-Alright, @anagasteyer
on TikTok.
Anyway...
-But you can only
watch it on a --
Your TikTok account you can
only watch on old IBMs.
-That's correct.
-Yeah, okay.
-It's very grainy,
and it's black and white,
but, God, is it funny.
Anyway, so he does --
So I've --
He's watching "SNL" now,
as they do as they get older.
And I'm educating him
into the classics,
and I'm trying to meet him
at his level,
which is my sense of humor,
which is all the fart sketches.
-Interesting, so you're sort of
going through the archives
and saying -- because, again,
there have been fart jokes
through the years.
-Since caveman times.
Yeah.
Yeah, well,
James Anderson's sketches,
I think, are the master.
-I mean, one of
the all-time great,
Mount Rushmore "SNL" writer.
-Mount Rushmore, yes.
So we watched -- Remember
the ghost hunter sketch
where Hugh Laurie farts?
-Yeah, and that's where they
have that sort of ghost camera,
and they keep picking up
the heat sensor of his farts.
-So stupid.
And all of them are like, "Let's
play it back in slow motion.
I think I hear a boy crying."
You know, the whole thing.
-I don't know if this is true,
but it feels like
that would be a sketch
where Kenan would be in it
and would say
there's a devilish smell.
[ Laughter ]
-So then we watched Kenan,
all the Kenans.
They're not necessarily
fart-related,
although who clogged the toilet
is a big hit.
-Big hit.
-Yeah, so it's super fun.
-Does he ever make you laugh
with his fart humor -- Ulysses?
-Yeah, I live -- I almost
don't want him to grow up
because I'm so happy with
his development in this area.
-Okay. Great.
-Yeah.
-It will be almost impossible
to replace once he leaves home.
-Almost impossible, yeah.
But I'll always be there.
-Yeah.
-But the -- the craftsmanship
is admirable.
A couple of weeks ago --
I'm not going to sell out
the family member --
but a certain member
of my family
may have emitted some gas,
and it had a trumpet quality.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm not going to say
who it was,
but it was pretty pronounced
trumpet sound.
And my son, Ulysses, marched
through the living room on cue
and went, "I did not realize
the king was in town."
[ Laughter ]
Which I thought
was a pretty great joke.
-That's really --
That's really nice.
-It was a nice delivery.
Yeah, it labeled it,
labeled the sound.
It set a scene.
-I would be so insanely proud
if one of my kids did that.
-I was, yeah.
-I would say, like, "Remember
that for your college essay."
[ Laughter ]
I got a lot to ask you
about "American Auto."
We'll be right back with more
from Ana Gasteyer, everybody.